sabías que la gastroenteritis puede
hacerte temporalmente intolerante a la
lactosa es verdad pues en este vídeo
vamos a platicar de cómo sucede esto y
de cómo funciona en detalle el intestino
delgado entonces a manera de repaso una
vez que ponemos comida en la cavidad
bucal o boca se mastica se envía al
esófago y termina en el estómago donde
se bate luego se introduce al ácido
donde se forma el quimo y se entrega la
primera parte del intestino delgado
ahora el intestino delgado tiene tres
partes diferentes echemos un vistazo la
primera parte del intestino delgado se
llama duodeno éste recibe el quimbo que
acaba de ser procesado en el estómago y
es la parte de todo el tracto
gastrointestinal donde ocurre la mayor
digestión la mayor descomposición de
productos alimenticios ocurrirá en el
duodeno muy bien entonces la siguiente
parte del intestino delgado se llama
yeyuno lo escribiré aquí yeyuno y esta
es la parte de todo el tracto
gastrointestinal donde ocurre la mayor
absorción así que la mayor absorción de
antes sucede en el yeyuno finalmente
después de que la comida pasa al jay uno
llega a la última parte del intestino
delgado que se llama y león' y aunque en
el león no se da la mayor absorción ni
una super digestión si hay cosas
bastante importantes que se absorben
aquí como la vitamina b-12 vitamina a d
acá sólo voy a escribir absorción
importante hay algunas cosas importantes
que se absorben en el león ahora la
parte más ocupada del intestino delgado
es el duodeno porque hay muchas cosas
que están involucradas en este proceso
de digestión por lo tanto hay cuatro
claves que debemos tener en cuenta en
primer lugar el estómago va a entregar
un manojo de equipo o comida procesada
al duodeno así que se va a trabajar con
todo ese equipo también habrá ciertos
ácidos estomacales que transforman los
alimentos en quimo eso va a estar
presente en el duodeno además del
estómago el hígado y la vesícula biliar
también van a ser importantes para
entregar bilis en el duodeno entonces
dan bilis
y como lo hablaré en un vídeo posterior
la bilis se compone de dos cosas
diferentes sales biliares y pigmentos
biliares y más allá del hígado y la
vesícula biliar el páncreas también
entrega un par de enzimas muy
importantes para la digestión de modo
que por ahora solo voy a escribir
enzimas y en un minuto voy a hablar
sobre qué enzimas son las que entrega el
páncreas finalmente el duodeno tiene lo
que se llama enzimas de borde en cepillo
eso es muy importante para la activación
de ciertas enzimas y también para la
digestión de varios nutrientes que vamos
a discutir hablemos un poco más sobre
este borde en cepillo ahora voy a hacer
un dibujo del duodeno recordemos que es
la primera parte de nuestro intestino
delgado dibujar es solo un pequeño tubo
conectado por aquí y luego voy a ampliar
la pared para ver mejor lo que está
pasando allí encontraremos muchas más
cosas de las que se pueden ver a simple
vista en primer lugar la pared no es
sólo una línea recta en realidad hay
muchos pliegues en la pared que ayudan a
aumentar el área de la superficie
piénsalo
estamos tratando de digerir tanto como
podamos debemos asegurarnos de que haya
mucho espacio donde podemos hacer
contacto con la comida qué pasa entonces
si este es el interior de nuestro
duodeno y este es el exterior tal como
lo dibujamos aquí esto es el interior y
exterior podemos notar que esta pared
tiene muchas proyecciones estas
proyecciones se llaman vellosidades una
sola de ellas se llama velocidad
solo una velocidad estos son un par de
pliegues que ayudan a aumentar la
superficie de nuestro duodeno ahora ahí
no es donde termina la historia si
echamos un vistazo más de cerca a una de
estas vellosidades encontraremos que hay
aún más proyecciones incluso
proyecciones microscópicas más pequeñas
para esta única velocidad que tenía una
línea horizontal aquí por su forma
notarás que no es una línea recta sino
que también tiene muchas proyecciones si
tuviéramos que adivinar por qué existen
todas estas proyecciones diríamos que
aumentan aún más nuestra superficie
es el nombre del juego cuando estamos en
el intestino delgado aumentar nuestra
superficie y estos pequeños se llaman
micro vellosidades de modo que tenemos
estas velocidades que podemos ver si
ampliamos la pared de duodeno y luego si
ampliamos una sola velocidad
encontraremos que tiene muchas micro
vellosidades para aumentar nuestra
superficie porque eso permite una mejor
digestión cuando decimos enzimas de
borde en cepillo son muchas enzimas que
están presentes en este borde en cepillo
piensen en eso estas velocidades y estas
micro vellosidades no son diferentes a
las cerdas de un peine actúan para
aumentar el área de superficie o lugares
donde vamos a tener interacción con la
comida que queremos digerir entonces hay
enzimas que están presentes en este
borde en cepillo sólo para aclarar el
punto todas estas micro vellosidades y
vellosidades juntas constituyen el borde
en cepillo de nuestro duodeno el borde
en cepillo que es el aumento del área de
la superficie de la pared ayuda a
digerir los alimentos con las enzimas
que están presentes y como veremos más
en el yeyuno ayuda a la absorción ahora
en otro vídeo hablaremos en detalle
sobre el proceso de digestión